been watching is about this book
comfortably numb' how psychiatry is
medicating a nation charles barber is
the author and now he joins us live from
Yale University in New Haven Connecticut
mr. barber thank you for being here to
talk about your book on book TV oh
thanks very much
mr. barber you used the the fact that
227 million prescriptions were written
for Americans for psychiatric drugs in
2006 why and how did we start to take so
many of these as a nation
well actually the number just went up
the the 2007 numbers were just released
and and they were 233 million and that's
actually not just psychiatric drugs
that's actually antidepressant
prescriptions just antidepressant
prescriptions making it them the most of
any class of medication there's a it's a
whole story here I talked about it in
the book is the the perfect storm and in
a nutshell the TV advertising of drugs
which happened in the 1990s which really
brought the sort of 20 top blockbuster
drugs in into the households really
almost household names and household
staples and a lot of those drugs were
where antidepressants the other big
brush issue was the expansion of
diagnosis of psychiatric diagnosis the
first edition of the the diagnostic
manual published by the American
Psychiatric Association had about 50
diagnoses in in the early 50s and the
latest one has over 300 and so diagnoses
have been expanded towards what I would
argue are far lesser conditions that
many people kind of relate to as opposed
to serious psychiatric conditions and
then the third piece is managed care
which happened really came to the fore
in in the early 90s and managed care has
clearly cast its lot with prescriptions
for mental health problems and made it
harder and harder for people to see
therapists have eroded the the
reimbursement rate so along with some
other factors that I'll probably get
into this hour those sort of three
things coming together have probably led
to
these massive astonishing rates that
that we're seeing now how much are drug
companies spending on advertising and is
it taking away from anything else in
your view yeah they they pretty
consistently spend double on marketing
that they do on on research and so you
know one would hope that that would be
sort of the inverse that research would
be there there the priority and and I
think the other factor in this is
there's been a concentration not just in
psychiatric drugs but but drugs in
general on on sort of lifestyle drugs so
the the shining examples being you know
Viagra and Cialis and and all that which
are you know heavily heavily advertised
and then arguably something like lipitor
is is a lifestyle enhancing drug and
arguably the antidepressants are and the
the the market base for people that
perceive that they have depressive
feelings or think that they have sexual
issues or are looking for things to help
them with their diet is much greater
than you know serious and persistent
mental illness or any serious health
condition you know generally speaking
that's a very small proportion of people
so the economics of it have sort of
favored and and there's been a push
towards these broad things that carry a
huge swath of the population with them I
I would argue and I argue in the book
that you know psychiatry should be
looking at the most serious conditions
first and and really concentrating our
our research you know on those sorts of
conditions oppression mr. Barbour I'm
sorry what is depression well
there-there's depression is a the most
common commonly given psychiatric
diagnosis the 40% of mental health
complaints result in the diagnosis of
depression according to the CDC
depression is marked by an inability to
feel pleasure that lasts for at least at
least two weeks and also a combination
of a lot of other symptoms
not being able to eat or eating too much
being able not be able to sleep or
sleeping too much having recurrent
thoughts of hurting oneself or having a
plan to hurt oneself and and and that
sort of thing well good morning and
welcome to our book TV audience this is
a live call-in on book TV with Charles
Barbour who is the author of comfortably
numb' how psychiatry is medicating a
nation - OH - as the area code for our
numbers 737 triple zero 1 if you live in
the eastern or central time zone 737
triple 0 - for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zone first
call up for Charles barber who's joining
us from Yale Atlanta Georgia
my question is he said that
psychiatrists they know major depression
when they see it you know kind of makes
me wonder if they just know what when
they see it or not
I know that particular criteria that
they're go by it's it seems to me it's
subjective I want to know if if they
know it when they see it
when do they know when a patient is
cured I'll one does the end and when the
disease well as the treatment begins I'm
one of the disease in mr. barber well
psychiatry is very murky you know there
there aren't so-called biomarkers or
tests to say that you have depression or
that you don't unlike you know a lot of
areas of Medicine and and I don't know
if there ever will be there you know
there's tremendous progress being made
in neuroscience but whether there will
be a black and white distinction I don't
know if that will ever happen
having said that an experienced
clinician will well no you know there
are formal diagnostic criteria that I
refer to but when you see someone with
serious major depressive disorder it
clearly is a horrific and malevolent
illness and as I say people are often at
risk of hurting themselves and to me was
very striking and you know I've worked
with people with serious mental illness
for a long time the risk for hurting
themselves is sometimes not actually at
the worst
abyss of the depression but actually
when people start to feel a little bit
better which to me sort of speaks to the
the severity of the illness it's
actually when you feel a little bit
better that you have the you know the
energy to muster to kill yourself so
it's it's a very profound malevolent
illness and what I argue in the book is
that we've kind of confused this major
depression this sort of capital D
depression with small D depression which
you know feeling bummed having the Blues
it's March I'm depressed quote-unquote
you know going through a divorce or
financial problems and and the
distinction between those two things is
is is Canoe as a confusion and I quote
william Styron in the book who says that
the word depression has slithered
innocuously through the english language
so in terms of trying to address your
question a lot of it is subjective
however when people are able to
re-engage in life in relationships in
work they're they're feeling capacity
for pleasure those are some of the
things that you look for for people
getting better for depression there is a
high recurrence rate so one of the
things that you want to look for is is
becoming aware of the illness and
warding off recurrent episodes and I
write in the book about cognitive
behavioral therapy for milder
depressions which can be very effective
in helping people learn the skills to
help ward off a future episode of
depression and some of the research
shows that the the relapse rates for
people that have gone through cognitive
behavioral therapy as opposed to just
taking the drugs that they have lower
relapse rates for depression because
they have the skills to manage a future
episode charles barber were idea you as
a lecturer and psychiatry at yale
university what do you lecture on i I am
actually not a psychiatrist or a
psychologist I have worked at Yale doing
research and I'm primarily a writer
these days I work with people on the
Yale faculty who were involved in the
so-called recovery movement
of in the mental health world which is
looking at people with severe mental
illness in how they've gotten better and
what are the factors that have gotten
them better and what you what you hear
when you listen to people with severe
mental illness that have you know I'm
talking here about schizophrenia or
bipolar disorder or major depression if
you interview them you hear some sort of
different messages than you might hear
from you know the drug advertising for
example so you'll you'll hear that the
recovery process is a prolonged process
so to look at the drug ads you know
there's sort of a facile transformation
you know one moment someone is looking
agonized and depressed and despairing
and then they're the drug will come
along sometimes it's literally in a
cartoon version and then you know the
next moment they're recovered and better
and there's beautiful music and a golden
retriever might be laughing at someone's
you know feed and their grandchildren or
at their knee when you talk to people
who have been there they talked about
the decades-long process of recovery and
that part of that recovery process
involves the acceptance of symptoms and
the fact is that most serious conditions
are chronic and so getting better
involves often learning how to live a
meaningful life in the presence of
ongoing symptoms so I've been involved
at Yale with the research of looking at
people with serious mental illness
hearing from them what has been
effective and also some some specific
interventions for example where we've
hired people with serious mental illness
to work on it on a so-called treatment
engagement team so one of things we did
was trying to reach out to people the
homeless mentally ill people who live
under bridges who are really out there
and there historically there have been
teams of people usually psychiatrists
and social workers that have tried to
engage you know the homeless mentally
ill into treatment you know why don't
you come into the shelter or how about
taking you know would you consider
taking these medications and a lot of
people for many
are very resistant to this what we did
is we we added a so called peer someone
who had had schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder who was really doing much much
better and we added them to this team
and it was a randomized clinical trial
where half the teams in Connecticut
didn't have this additional peer worker
and half the teams did and what we found
was that the the number of contacts with
the recipients of care the homeless
people living under bridges was much
higher when this peer was added there
the so called treatment Alliance the the
feeling on the part of the recipient
that they were understood and heard was
significantly higher and the attendance
in you know very concrete things like
AAA and NA meetings Narcotics Anonymous
meetings was much better so we found a
very effective way of engaging people so
that the treatment engagement is is what
I've been involved in with a lot
Palmetto Florida thanks for holding your
own with Charles Barbour hello thank you
for taking my call I have two daughters
who have schizophrenia and I've been up
against the treatment trying to get them
treatment I think there's a stigmatism
attached to people with serious mental
illness
and I don't think that this can be
addressed the core problem which is our
government's irresponsible failure to
treat the seriously mentally ill because
there's not as much profit in it for
people who are going for say you know
everyday depression
Charles Barbour yeah you know the the
National Institute of Mental Health has
been criticized for not funding research
for serious and percent persistent
mental illness like schizophrenia as
much as they should and there's been you
know an emphasis some would argue on on
milder conditions I would agree with you
I think there is sort of a triage factor
where we need to concentrate on the most
severely ill first and one of the
ironies of the the medication revolution
when we were talking earlier in the
in the hour about these astonishing
rates of antidepressants is that you
could almost argue that your chances of
being in treatment go up as the severity
of your condition goes down and so if
you go to a cocktail party with
upper-middle class people you know
especially when people learn what I do
I'm very often told you know people I'm
taking you know lexapro or something
and as this revolution has occurred
which really just started in the late
80s with with Prozac the the rates of
effective treatment for people with
serious illness mental illness have not
gone up very much depending on what
study you look at only about half the
people with severe conditions like your
daughters are really getting treatment
and and some studies have shown only one
in six are really getting adequate
treatment and those numbers haven't
changed that much so there's a
tremendous sort of irony in this and and
I would totally agree with you that we
should be concentrating on people like
your daughters where there has been
progress in in the drugs and treatment
but we need to concentrate on that
primarily in my in my opinion Columbia
South Carolina good morning good morning
Peter thanks for taking my call mr.
Barbour uh yeah I was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder in 1999 at the age of
42 which seems to be a typical as far as
generally bipolar is diagnosed when
you're in your teens are adolescents
saying am I not correct about that
yeah or early adulthood yeah I was going
through a traumatic separation with my
wife and I did have a full-blown
delusional psychotic episode and was
emergent underwent an emergency
hospitalization since then I've been on
lots of different medications have tried
to wean myself off of them as much as
possible to be able to function D do you
know what the long-term impact of some
of the newer medications atypical
antipsychotics like seroquel and geodon
will have on my
to function if I stay on them for a you
know 10 or 20 years as they've seen the
want made me do my major symptoms I have
now our anxiety and debilitating panic
attacks and I I knock those back with
xanax and alcohol and they seem to work
pretty well mr. barber yeah you know
again I'm not a psychiatrist or a
psychologist have worked with the the
seriously mentally ill for for about 20
years in an informed writer so I don't
want to give you clinical advice I would
say that the the antipsychotics have
been used more and more and for kids for
example where the use of antipsychotics
were were more or less taboo
there's been really huge increases in
the rates of antipsychotics and and you
know I think that we need to be careful
and judicious in the use of the
medications and also I found in talking
to a lot of neuroscientists that the
really top neuroscientists told me we
don't fully understand how these drugs
work and so I think one needs to be
careful and if there are other
approaches that work for you in
consultation with your psychiatrist you
should you should be looking at those I
want to read a little bit from your book
mr. barber and have you respond this is
in the chapter the commerce of mood only
only 20 new drugs were approved by the
FDA in 2005 as compared to 53 in 1996
the pipeline problem as it is called
speaks to the serious lack of creativity
on the part of the industry many of the
new drugs are actually developed not at
the big drug companies but at
universities small biotech firms and the
National Institutes of Health
Big Pharma has cast instead cast its lot
with the pharmaceutical equivalent of
picking low-hanging fruit in recent
years the industry Giants have largely
gone in for producing what are called me
to drugs slight variants on existing
blockbuster medications rather than
searching for something truly new yeah
well that's that's been the case and
what you find in
in psychiatric drugs is that there's a
paradigm that most of the drugs follow
so the first psychiatric drugs were
discovered by accident in largely in the
1950s and 1960s
Thorazine being the the sort of
breakthrough drug for schizophrenia and
and most drugs first for schizophrenia
for psychotic disorders have followed in
that paradigm in that in in the the
chemical paradigm of of Thorazine and
then there were other drugs in the early
90s that had some variation but by and
large it's much easier to kind of make a
slight variant on an existing drug than
to look at a you know an entirely new
way of looking at you know at the New
York chemistry and the economics favored
that and and so there's been a this sort
of me2 quality to most of the new drugs
I spoke to a very eminent neuroscientist
who was retired and I think perhaps as a
result of that sort of spoke very freely
and and I asked him you know why do all
the psychiatric drugs primarily deal
with four neurotransmitters dopamine and
serotonin are the best known and he and
he said you know I said is that because
those are the ones that are most thought
to be implicated with mood and thought
problems and he said no it's because
they are following the paradigms of the
first drugs and and continuing in that
vein and it's conceivable that there are
dozens of others of neurotransmitters
out there that could have just as
profound a relationship and therapeutic
relationship with mental illness but the
economics have sort of branching into a
totally new area are not favorable but
hopefully we'll get there and there's
you know we're sort of at the tip of the
iceberg of looking at many many
different ways of treating the illnesses
and many other neurotransmitters that
maybe have therapeutic benefit Vancouver
Washington you're on book TV good
morning mr. barber it seems like the
consumer movement accomplished some very
important things such as you know
getting rid of the horrible state
hospitals that we had
forty or fifty years ago however I would
question it seems like that we have a
situation now where you have to be an
immediate risk to yourself or others in
order to be hospitalized I don't think
most people realize that you know if you
do what society wants you to do if
you're having really bad thoughts and
you go to a hospital you won't be
admitted unless you're in risk an
immediate risk to yourself or others and
do you worry that the consumers movement
and the recovery model is being used as
a Trojan horse to actually tear down
what's left of our pitiful mental health
system in the name of evidence-based
practices do you have any concern about
that you said I didn't quite understand
the what you the last question that you
asked the Trojan horse part he is gone I
apologize okay when I first started
working in mental health I was shocked
that the the caller's right the criteria
for for getting hospitalized is
basically hurting yourself or being at
risk of hurting yourself or hurting
somebody else I was sort of under the
naive impression that you know distress
severe distress was a way to get
hospitalized and I think that's you know
incredibly narrow way of looking at
things
in terms of the consumer movement what
he means by that what I mean by that
again is listening to the voices of
people with mental illness who tell you
much different things about how they get
better and and and what's helped them
and and psychiatry the more progressive
aspects of psychiatry and academic
psychiatry have really started to listen
to these voices so for example if you
apply for a federal grant the Samsa is
the mental health and substance abuse
administration the grant making
Administration of the National Institute
of Health for research on mental illness
and you will are required or it's highly
advisable to interview the future
recipients of your grant so for example
if you're trying to engage people the
homeless mentally ill the the research
that I've been involved with what you'll
be strongly suggested to do
is interview those folks and ask them
well if you were designing a program
like this you know what would be most
effective and that's been an incredibly
beneficial voice to be heard that the
sort of the old medical paradigm was you
know the psychiatrist is in charge you
do what you know I tell you to do
largely based on medications largely
based on these very narrow criteria like
whether you're you know risk yourself or
others and what we're hearing whereas
the patient's voice or the consumers
voice has been brought into the dialogue
including by federal funding sources is
that that whole dialogue and way of
looking at illness and how one gets
better has been vastly broadened and and
I think that's a very exciting
development the Zanesville Ohio
you're on with Charles Barbour hi
Charles
my name is Dungey trails and I have a
year and a week in recovery prior I had
eight years I had to take xanax several
years at the very end I was on methadone
I ended up relapsing the death of my
mother I want to speak for the American
Indians and also our military we have a
lot of homeless soldiers out there and
they are drugs and alcohol and and no
food and thank you sometimes to be that
way but other times we don't we get
pushed out our medical is going downhill
okay I take those back it helped me a
lot and gather fit I'm sure you've heard
of it mm-hmm and I just love your
program and I would like to get your
book it's very important for all of us I
would love to go to the reservations and
try to help our Indians they have so
much alcohol and you know our soldiers
all right they're getting a dollar we
got the point thanks for calling in this
morning
Charles Barbour thank you Matt any car
like that no no thank you Freeman
California you're on the air hi good
morning thank you Peter for taking my
call I know you guys are very busy there
I also have signed up mr. Barbour thank
you for being there as well oh thank you
yeah thank you so much I wanted to let
you both know that when I was a teenager
my sister who's four years younger than
me
never succeeded in society issues like I
did and here we are 30 years later she
takes two pills and she she doesn't have
the society things that I have and here
we are that she's not successful at life
at all and I have morte an abundance of
it and I feel very guilty
so I'd you call her almost every other
day and try to motivate her but I wonder
if there's something else in the drugs
Pharma guy that I see in your book there
that would help her so she's gonna have
to overcome her issues that are like
stumbling blocks to her okay thank thank
you for the question
I argue in the book that as we very much
concentrated on the drugs and that the
marketing of the drugs and attention
towards the drugs and as during the same
time period there's been really really
interesting and thoughtful research
about how to engage and motivate people
into treatment largely coming out of the
substance abuse field so I write about
two models in the book in a chapter
called the human factor and one is
called the stages of change model and
the other is called motivational
interviewing and and it's sort of a
revolution in the way looking at how
people change and and again from the
substance abuse model the old model was
sort of you there motivated to change or
you're not and if you're not motivated
we really can't help you and there's
been a far more nuanced understanding of
how people change that first came out of
how they change in relation to using
substances but has now been generalized
to mental health issues and and other
other health issues and basically it
going from a thinking of change
is not as a linear process but a
cyclical process and so one is at
various places on a cycle and so the the
first part of the cycle might be called
pre contemplation which is where you you
don't even think you have a problem and
you're not even thinking about changing
but you in fact do have a problem and
then contemplation would be you've got
an issue and you're just starting to
think about doing something about it
but you're not yet doing something about
it and then preparation would be the
next stage in the cycle again it's a
it's a linear it's a circular thing
preparation is okay I've got a problem
I'm going to start to do something
action would be your start you're really
starting to address it and so the
motivational interviewing which was
developed by a guy called William Miller
at the University of New Mexico brings
in different strategies on how you work
with people at different stages of that
cycle so what you would do with a pre
contemplate er is much different that
you would do someone in the preparation
stage and how you would even engage with
them and talk to them would be quite
different so there's a new book bringing
motivational interviewing to mental
health issues
edited by CAI called Hal ARCA whit's and
William Miller by Guilford press it just
came out and I think that that's very
exciting in a very nuanced way of how
you work with people and I have found
that in working with the people that
I've worked with how you engage people
how you approach people can be
tremendously important in motivating
them to treatments so you know that sort
of thing might have some relevance to
your sister who sounds like she's sort
of stuck Charles Barbour you seem to
have been very careful on in the naming
of your book not to use the term
overmedicated is America over medicated
yes absolutely I I think I make it very
clear in the book and I'd like to make
it very clear in every interview I do
that for for serious conditions the
medications can be very very helpful and
I've seen over and over again you know
the life-saving implications of the
medications for schizophrenia for
bipolar for the major depression that I
was talking about earlier but what's
happened with that with the marketing
and this sort of relent
attention to the drugs over some of
these other approaches cognitive
behavioral therapy as I talked about
earlier being a formal clinical approach
that's very effective for for milder
depression as that we've we've so
seriously looked at the meds as opposed
to other ways of doing things and so
what you what you see with these
astonishing numbers you know that the
230 million prescriptions is that
clearly there's not you know tens of
millions of people with serious
depression and a lot of those
prescriptions are probably being written
for lifestyle problems for life problems
I literally have talked to people who
have told me you know they were
prescribed the drugs because they didn't
like their boss you know they were under
stress from their boss or they couldn't
afford their SUV or one woman told me
that the the doctor said you look
depressed I think you should take
antidepressants and and I think that
that confusion is dilatory as' and and
premature and in in Britain there
there's guidelines for the National
Health Service for milder depression
they asked for watchful waiting changes
in diet changes in exercise
self-help counseling therapy cognitive
behavioral therapy all those things
before going to antidepressants and I
think it's sort of the opposite in our
culture and so again my point is not
that the drugs can't be very effective
but we've so relentlessly focused on the
drugs as the first line of treatment
where the very subtle and important
research has been done as I refer to the
motivational interviewing the cognitive
behavioral therapy that just hasn't
gotten the press because there's no
money to market it so don't you know
people just don't know about it why are
other nations different then why are we
taking 2/3 of the depression and mental
health drugs we're not taking 2/3 of the
drugs we account for two-thirds of the
sales the global sales of
antidepressants that's an important
point to clarify but the drugs were
largely developed here a lot of the big
drug
companies are American but I think it's
more of a cultural phenomena I think
that the TV advertising is is a is
largely a uniquely American phenomenon
it's only the United States and New
Zealand that allow that the TV
advertising of drugs so if you were to
pick one thing that has pushed this
stuff it would be that primetime you
know high-profile advertising of the
drugs I also think it fits in with a
sort of uniquely American way of looking
at illness that we are very quick to
want to medicate to use technology to
have a quick fix
you know our society is impatient with
complexity you can perhaps see that at a
political level and so we are prone to
want to kind of get rid of things as
quickly as possible and and in the most
expedient form possible and and some of
these more subtle social approaches and
looking at the social context of how
people change are require work so so
cognitive behavioral therapy for example
it is actually unlike many forms of
psychotherapy it's time limited it's
very structured it's very practical it's
often 12 to 15 sessions where explicit
goals are set out at the beginning of
the therapy but there it you know it's
work you actually have to do homework
you you look at a situation in which
you've been depressed or anxious and you
analyze the thoughts and beliefs and and
the and the patterns that lie behind
those conditions and how you react to
them and the skills that you might
deploy in future situations so it
requires some introversion some homework
some you know really looking at one's
issues and I think you know that's sort
of an unamerican thing you know we kind
of like the quick and easy solution in
other cultures in Japan for example
there wasn't really a word for a
depression because people thought of
depression in a much different way
depression was construed by some as
being a sign of awareness
of artistic sensibility and so that's
another sort of factor is that in the
American context we see sad and untoward
and unhappy emotions is something that
we've got to kind of get rid of as
quickly as possible other cultures don't
necessarily see them that way and so
there's a there's a series of technical
issues that you know the advertising of
the drugs and managed-care
and all that and then there's a social
context in which the drugs have been
embraced that I think is equally
important
Detroit good morning good morning thank
you for taking my call I am glad that
this information is being shared I had a
couple of points that I wanted to ask
you about I'm a big fan of dr. William
glasses work and I wondered if you give
his ideas and credibility also I was
curious about your perceptions of the
implications of a nation being
comfortably numb I I believe that a lot
of the anxiety that people suffer from
and helpful quotation marks around the
word suffer is a result of the
dysfunction in our society and I'm
concerned that if we are truly a nation
that's comfortably numb that there could
be implications that might not be so
healthy with regard to democratic
engagement in the political system that
might allow for some changes I'm not I'm
not aware of mr. William blasters work I
think that one of the social factors
that you see here is is isolation and
which relates to civic engagement or
disengagement as you put it I was very I
don't write about it much in the book I
was very influenced by Robert putnams
book Bowling Alone which is basically
filled with a hundred charts and they
all go like this and they're they're
measures of social engagement whether
it's union membership or PTA membership
or charitable giving membership in
fraternal or you know civic
organizations and and in bowling leagues
which is where the title comes from and
and the charts all go like this
and they they they chart say the early
1900s to our present decade and you find
that membership and all these collective
activities sort of hit their peak in the
60s and 70s and then drop precipitously
in the 80's 90's in this decade and one
thing is for sure that isolation
baguettes depression and depression
baguettes isolation and again I'm not so
much talking about the serious clinical
major depression but the sort of life
issue the life problems of sadness and
depression and isolation and so I I
think that you know there have been
various studies there was a study about
the declining number of confidants that
Americans have non-kin confidence either
that people feel comfortable sharing you
know personal problems with and how
that's declined every decade over the
last two or three decades and I think
that that's all part of this phenomenon
of so-called depression and and it plays
out in the in political disengagement
maybe that's changing and with this
election perhaps and then I think you
know other technologies like the
internet and all of which can be a
wonderful thing but we're all sort of I
write in the book about how part of this
depression phenomenon and again I'm
talking about them the small D
depression not clinical major depression
is you know we're all sort of live in
our own private Idaho's and our kind of
Edward Hopper ish aspects of isolation
and living in our own kind of virtual
bubbles has increased you know
dramatically in the last decade or two
at the same time that rates of
depression have gone up and so I do
think that the the social disengagement
and the the milder forms of depression
or what we construe as depression but is
really sort of sadness or and loneliness
are correlated I don't know if that
answers your question but those are some
thoughts that come up in relation to
what you said Charles Barbour is the
author of comfortably numb' we have
about eight minutes left with him Toccoa
Georgia you're on the air thank you
Scott Marshall here thank you for book
TV and the intellectual stimulation that
it is on the weekend my wife Amy is
going to be pursuing a master of Social
Work degree
she'll be encountering what you referred
to earlier the DSM the psychiatric Bible
I just had couple quick questions most
people don't even know about this book
but yet it's cultural impact and
influence is is huge and do you think it
has any credibility issues of her
there's connections with people who are
in this book or
created this book and the drug companies
and then finally are you familiar with
dr. Seth Farber's work I've heard of him
but I'm not familiar with his work I I
think that the you know and there have
been studies that have shown that the
high rates of people that that wrote the
DSM and that they've consulted with the
drug companies and so on I think that
the DSM has a high degree of credibility
and is a very effective book when we're
talking about serious disorders so I've
as I've referred it spent a lot of time
working with people with schizophrenia
I think the diagnostic criteria for
schizophrenia are are excellent they
make a tremendous amount of sense when
you work with people suffering from that
condition or major depression as I
talked about earlier so they to me they
very match up with what I seen working
with people with serious conditions my
issue with the DSM is the expansion of
diagnosis so you will find diagnoses in
the DSM like adjustment disorder which
is essentially you know having
difficulty adjusting to a major life
change or you'll see categories there
the so-called V codes there there's all
section of the DSM where there's there's
labels like phase of life problem or
sibling relational issues and I think
what psychiatry has done is gone from
concentrating on the the seriously
mentally ill to these with this
expansion of some of these to my mind
very iffy diagnosis or categories of
distress to life that the things are not
mental illness is that whatsoever that
are life problems that are very painful
that require you know attention but they
are not
mental illnesses and so I I think that
psychiatry would be better served if it
focused on what especially as we
understand the neuroscience better in
the physiological aspects of these
disease to concentrate on the diseases
the really major diseases and to me it's
very watered down and you could are the
these sort of lesser diagnoses and you
could argue that there's a self-serving
nature to this that basically what
happened post-world War two is that
social workers and psychologists came
along and they started to treat the the
worried well as opposed to people with
serious disorders and then psychiatry is
a way of sort of matching that expanded
to you know the cash carrying worried
well who tend to show up for their
appointments and you know is
reimbursable by insurance and are a lot
easier to work with then you know people
with schizophrenia so there's a certain
expediency and perhaps a sort of
countermeasure that psychiatry kind of
expanded its diagnostic range in
response to a turf war with social
workers and psychologists Bristol
Connecticut uh hi thank you for taking
my call I have um my name is Barbara and
I have three quick comments and
questions my shirt was diagnosed about
two years ago with bipolar and he was
diagnosed after having a totally manic
hallucinogenics episode on the road
coming back from burning in out west and
I'm just curious in your work with the
homeless how many patients after they
were medicated with bipolar drugs said
listen I'm I know where my home is can
you help me get there how many times did
that happen and then my other quick
question is how when do we start having
the doctors take responsibility for the
over prescriptions Charles Barbara
I didn't understand your first question
about the number of patients that I
worked with what percentage I'm sorry
didn't catch that or have you left as
well she is gone okay you know the
doctors are under pressure for a managed
care to see X number of people they've
got patients coming in who have seen
these ads on television the the ads
often say ask your doctor if so in such
a such drug is right for you and and the
research has shown that the doctors
especially family doctors now prescribe
most antidepressants in this country
will prescribe the drugs at times even
if they feel ambivalent about the
appropriateness of the choice for the
patient there's actually a study where a
very enterprising researcher hired
people to act depressed they were not
depressed and to go in and ask doctors
for medications and they were given
drugs very high proportion of the time I
think doctors need to stand up a little
bit more and and look more carefully at
the prescribing practices to try and
family doctors you know to understand
the the the criteria for depression do
better screenings so that they're really
giving out these meds more appropriately
and I think the other thing is follow-up
you know the reality of this is that
when a family doctor writes a
prescription for Zoloft
you know how likely is is that they're
really going to be following the patient
and when people have difficulties with
these drugs it's often when they're
starting the drugs or when they're
getting off the drugs and I argue very
much for the role of psychiatrists to be
prescribing and involved in the
prescription of Saiki of psychiatric
drugs because they are much more likely
to be you know experts and also to do
the follow up that I think is very
critical so I think I I think the
doctors need to be a little tougher in
in resisting some of the pressures that
they're under from patients themselves
and from managed care the book is called
comfortably numb how psychiatry
is medicating a nation the author as
Charles barber it's published by
pantheon Charles barber is a lecturer at
Yale University if people want to
contact you mr. barber what's the best
way for them to get ahold of you my
website which is Charles barber writing
dot-com and barber is VAR BER and it may
take me a while but I attempt to answer
every inquiry and also want to remind
our viewers that if you'd like to see
this again you can go to book TV org
also reminder that all next week we will
be live in primetime on book TV you can
catch the schedule at book TV org thank
you